the thing that that I found really
interesting about this drug is that it
produces what I think is probably the
most stereotyped trip if you want to
call it or the psychological phenomenon
that that happens alongside the drug
effects and so people will describe this
earlier life autobiographical replaying
of emotionally Salient memories that are
kind of epock in time and so and they'll
some people got would got life revieww
right rev or slideshow yeah exactly and
so you know it's interesting everybody's
kind of got a different different
version of what the slideshow ends up
playing out to be like for them and so
some people would say I found myself in
this room and it was like my TV from
childhood and all of a sudden it was
playing all these things or I found
myself in a Hall of Mirrors and it was
playing all these things so like the
context can be very different you know
but the act the mind seems to shape that
but the actual replay seems to be pretty
stereotyped stereotype meaning like this
it's a pattern that that repeats or it's
it just like a common characteristic
it's a common characteristic and it's
you know closed eye only it's not open
eyes it's not for a lot of people the
the Iain experience is kind of really
around this this part this kind of
Replay part that happens and from what I
have heard there's there's kind of a a
cathartic re-evaluation of these
memories and in and interestingly an
ability to not only have insights into
your own reasons which may have been
good or bad for feeling or behaving or
doing whatever it was but also reasons
for they have some insight in the
reasons for the other which to me is
like the hardest thing to explain it's
it's almost like you knew it say it one
more time say the last part again so
when they when people have this
slideshow or Life review they seem to
have it as a as a third- party person in
the experience you know like what is
this Christmas Carol Scrooge or whatever
when they go back in they go back in
life and you see like you become the
Observer of your own past experience
right it's kind of like that like
Scrooge goes back and sees himself as a
kid sees himself as like when he broke
up with his significant you know all
that stuff it's almost like that like
you're having a similar sort of thing
I've used the analogy of Tom Cruz in The
Minority Report right where you're able
to go back and see these events and and
what's so fascinating and why I've why
I've said and I I continue to say I
think this is the most sophisticated
drug on the planet
is that I think that there's nothing
else that can seem to do this right
where you have these experiences where
you you're able to hold this neutral
place and you're able to have this sense
of where you were and why you did what
you did and you have this sense of the
other and you're able to I don't know
intu it you know empath I I don't know
what that is you you somehow you know
stored it at the time and you weren't
able to fully access it and you're able
to access it whatever that is
being able to forgive or to forget or to
understand this person's position as
well as your own and then seemingly like
unlock the lock on both sides and then
kind of dissolve the the problem people
say they'll they kind of would work
through all of this and you know there's
one one veteran you know would say I
went through all this military stuff and
at the back of of the room it was my
Early Childhood trauma you know and so
this idea that
that at the core of it for a lot of this
ends up being a childhood trauma thing
that's kind of buried below all of it
and really being able to actually both
access that in a way that you can
understand understand that in many cases
the traumatizer was themselves
traumatized and that it's a pattern of
trauma and the ability to kind of
resolve it by understanding it this kind
of you know more meta empathic Viewpoint
and so that's why I think the tools
really going to be important you know is
this ability to have what seems to be a
pretty profound or atrophic effect you
know we were able to see disability
improvements from traumatic brain injury
but also this pretty pronounced kind of
cathartic reevaluation reconsolidation
of of past life you know problematic
memories